when my nephew walks out of the door
i worry for him you're not 100 sure
whether they're coming home or not
these accounts are from six black people
that have experienced racial
discrimination in their respective
countries
how would you describe your upbringing
growing up in america has been
a very complex and interesting
relationship
i'm from brooklyn new york born and
raised
i was born very cultured always thought
about my roots
i always thought to be proud of myself
be proud of my skin complexion be
proud of my lineage but when you step
outside of your house
the world in society teaches us a
slightly different narrative
of what it means to be black growing up
in japan was interesting
because from 12 years old to 18 years
old i lived on a yokota air base
it was a u.s air force base so i went to
an american school
my teachers taught in english i have
america teachers
we use dollars on base we still use
gallons in fahrenheit
outside of yokota right outside the gate
is the real japan they use celsius they
use
kilometers they use japanese yen for
their money
we had a community however small it was
there's
a few people who looked like me who look
like americans you know
there is a lot of life in south africa
there is a lot
of joy there is a lot of
pride in what is now known as the
rainbow nation
but i think that image of the rainbow
nation
also blindsided people to what's
actually happening
what majority of the country is actually
experiencing if i'm describing kailisha
kevicha is a township
that was created under a
rule it is where majority
black middle to lower class people live
and it is what you would expect in that
area there is a lot of
like complexity in the
beauty you kind of see in this area
because you see
you know this beautiful area of vibrancy
and people who
are so grateful for life but you also
see their situations and you also see
their
realities and their lived experiences
which kind of contrast this beauty
and it's sort of that kind of experience
do you think other countries are aware
of the racial inequality that happens in
your country
i think people who are outside of
australia
are acutely aware of the racial
inequality
however it's not widely reported on
and so i think people have a very
idolized version of what they love the
country
the uk birthed the us so to think that
the uk is not racist
is stupid we taught the us racism i
don't say we invented it
but we definitely perfected it we
perfected it so much so that
the people in this country think that
racism doesn't exist i think the
difference is
i like to call the us a baby country and
because you know
the us is quite new and as a baby
country they're in their toddler phase
and they're still really really loud
the uk is very mature we're the mature
older sister that can
suppress and really be vindictive with
their own doings
so as the us says racism is so over
it's in your face ours is like very
underlying you know i think that people
think of canada
they think that we're so polite and you
know
we're multicultural and
there couldn't possibly be racism here
but there's a lot of racism here people
of color
experience it almost every day
it needs to be known something needs to
be said about it because we're always so
quiet
and you know at this point in time i'm
done being polite
i'm done being quiet i look at the
torture that i live in
it's about 28 minutes from central cape
town
which is the touristy area with table
mountain and waterfront
so when a tourist is visiting south
africa they might choose to go to places
like
robben island table mountain waterfront
all of the
beautiful instagram-worthy places
people are living very different lives
from what you're seeing from those
instagram pictures
an interesting thing is that many
children of color don't get to go to
these tourist areas
even though they're right here in their
countries just because it's such a
luxury
and so i think as someone coming in from
a different country
you might choose to not see it because
you're here for a good time
can you recall an instance of racial
discrimination the first time i felt
racism i was i think i was around seven
years old in our school i went to an old
girl school
it was basically you know what it is
it's the policy that if you're gonna
invite one person to your birthday party
you must invite
everybody to your birthday party a girl
in my class her birthday party had come
around
she gave everybody invitations for her
birthday i was like
one of the only black kids in class and
when it came to me she was like oh i'm
really sorry i can't give you an
invitation because my mum says
i can't have any people like you at my
birthday party i was in
elementary and there were four little
white girls that
tormented me and my sister and we used
to fight
every day every single day we fought
because those four girls love to use
that
n-word and you know i didn't really know
why it was a bad word i just knew that
it was bad and it used to hurt like
every time they said it
would hurt my stomach i was
working for a company where there was a
racial dispute
and when i brought it up
i was fired it made me feel unsafe
it made me feel as though i couldn't
use my voice in a constructive way
it made me really depressed i remember
being stopped by the police
because i was driving my mother's car
and they couldn't believe
that a young black man i guess was
driving in infinity
they didn't think it was my car they
thought i stole it
and after that instance which
unfortunately a lot of black people go
through
um you start to see very skewed
perceptions of what it means to be black
in america
the cop stopped me pretty much my entire
stay there out of the 17 years i've been
stopped without fail
multiple times i've been stopped by the
cops for standing in a corner
daytime or night time i've been searched
my backpack has been searched my shoes
have been searched my underwear has been
searched you know and there's no problem
protecting your home
the issue is why are you stopping me
when i'm trying to get to my english
class to teach your kids
how has the racial protests in the u.s
affected your country
so the protests and everything that you
see on tv
with regards to america it's really lit
a fire under us
to say hey it's happening there but it's
happening here too
don't think that just because we live in
canada and
you know it's not as blatant that it's
not
still happening when the black lives
matter movement
got a lot of attention in terms of the
media that
magnified the issues of like
police brutality in south africa that
has been happening
and during lockdown there's been this
fear around the south african defense
force
um monitoring townships and other areas
like that because they tend to be very
violent
the timing was so good i mean it's a bad
thing but the timing was so good because
then
the two issues sort of combined
and a lot more attention was now put on
it and a lot more attention was put to
get justice
or many victims in south africa who were
hurt or
died under the hands of police i'm so
proud of the black community
globally for really coming together and
deciding
in this time of pandemic as if we don't
have other things to think about but we
have come together as a collective and
said
it is enough we will not stop
[Music]
unfortunately this is something that
every black person
in my opinion experiences once in some
way shape or form
whether it's microaggressions whether
it's direct
whether it's subtle it's there you can't
take off this uniform and stuff
we stand out worldwide it isn't a lot
that we're asking for
we're just asking to be treated like
human beings
just give me the same recognition the
same human rights
as my white neighbor and that's it if a
non-black person
is in a place where they are willing to
look at their own internal biases
the lived experiences that they hear
from black peoples and and the
information
and the education they get from black
people becomes
easier to understand and easier to
empathize with because
you're now aware of your non-black
identity
i think we have a long way to go but i
think
as long as we're having the
conversations we're
on the right path
[Music]
you